[Arabic recitation]
What month is it?
The will Hijjah. Very good.
And we are in the first 10 days of the
will Hijjah, correct?
In Sahih al-Bukhari
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam said
there are no days
in which
good deeds are more beloved to Allah
than during these days
speaking about the first 10 days of the
month of Dhul Hijjah.
The month of Dhul Hijjah
is the last 12th and final month of the
Islamic lunar calendar.
It is the time when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala chose
for us
to make our pilgrimage
to
Mecca
to visit al-Bayt al-Atiq
and to make our Hajj, to make our Umrah.
And so
that is the first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah
and that is why
Eid and the greatest of Eid
comes on the 10th day of Zulhijjah.
Why? Because that is the capstone of all
culminated efforts throughout the entire
year. There are no days
in which righteous good deeds are more
beloved to Allah. What does that mean
beloved?
Beloved meaning Allah loves them. He
loves good deeds the most during these
10 days.
So, what does that translate to? Well,
that
that translates to Allah accepting those
good deeds, Allah overlooking our sins,
Allah forgiving and expiating our
misdeeds, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
writing for us
our merits doubly and exponentially.
Every merit that a person earns is worth
at least 10 times.
But during the first 10 days of
Zulhijjah, it is far more.
Good deeds are multiplied during these
days.
And bad deeds are magnified during these
10 days.
These 10 days Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has mentioned
in a number of places in the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
[Silence]
The days
The days The The
[Arabic recitation]
commanded that we remember him generally
and that we make mention of him
and remember him specifically
during
a known number of days. Those known
number of days, they are
in they they are not in need of an any
introduction. They are known to
everyone. Even the disbelievers of
Mecca, the idolaters recognize these
first 10 days of Dhu al-Hijjah as being
these supreme days of the year.
And so during these days, Allah says,
"Wadkurullah." Remember Allah. The
remembrance of Allah doesn't just mean
that a person says, "Subhanallah,
[Arabic recitation]
Akbar."
that is remembrance of Allah, but every
time a person does a good deed, that is
remembrance of Allah.
Correct? When a person does a good deed,
let's say you're walking down the
sidewalk and there's piece of trash or
something in the sidewalk and you move
it out of the way
because you know the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam used to do this, you
know this is part of iman, you are
worshipping Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala by
doing this.
That is a remembrance of Allah. Why?
Because in it's it's an expression
of being driven solely by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The person is driven by Allah.
The main focus, what is driving his
actions, is the remembrance of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. And it is expressed
by way of good deeds.
And so, when Allah says,
what is meant here is that excel, work
hard to do good deeds. And this is where
the prophet
understood this narration from. He says
there are no days in which good deeds
are more beloved to Allah than during
these first 10 days.
Some
of the Sahaba
and them
explained the statement of Allah Subhana
[Arabic recitation]
Walayalin Ashrin
as the first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah.
The scholars differ
on this verse. Is it the first 10 days
of Dhul Hijjah or the last 10 nights of
Ramadan? Ramadan
is not
one of the
four sacred months.
The four sacred months we are smack-dab
in the middle of them right now.
The The four sacred months are
Dhul Qa'dah, Dhul Hijjah, Muharram, and
Rajab.
And so, we are in Dhul Hijjah right now.
These are days that Allah has chosen
that be the days when we are most
excellent. All of our efforts throughout
the year, including Ramadan,
were intended to be working up towards
these 10 days.
If a person wishes
to be on the path to Allah, wishes to be
close to Allah, wishes to be near to
Allah, wishes to change his ways, wishes
to be better, wishes to make amends,
wishes to be able to look himself in the
mirror properly,
then there is no more opportune time
than these 10 days. Every time you say
Allah's name during these 10 days, it is
multiplied and exponentially
reciprocated by Almighty Allah Rabbil
Alamin.
[Arabic recitation]
when they heard the prophet say this,
they heard him say there is no days in
which good deeds are more beloved to
Allah than these 10 days,
they said not even jihad fi sabilillah.
What greater expression
of
servitude
to Allah
than a person offering up his own soul
in martyrdom?
Is there any greater offering a person
can make?
Person is literally taking the fabric of
their being
and putting it in harm's way and placing
it at hazard in order that Allah's name
be the highest and his word reigns
complete, reigns supreme.
This is the greatest expression
of worship and servitude to Allah. So
the companions asked, not even jihad fi
sabilillah is more virtuous than good
deeds during these days? He said not
even jihad fi sabilillah. Unless a
person were to take all of his
possessions, all of his wealth, all of
his property, and go out to fight fi
sabilillah and return with none of those
things, including his own soul.
Return in a bag.
That is the only thing that is more
virtuous than good deeds during these 10
days.
The narration of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
where he tells us that Allah himself has
said
[Silence]
Notice the wording of the narration. He
says that if my servant reaches out to
me a handspan, this is a handspan in the
Arabic language.
This is called a handspan.
If a person reaches out to Allah a
handspan,
Allah will reach back out to him how
long how much?
A cubit.
Is from the elbow
to the tip of the middle finger,
which is almost exactly twice of a
handspan, correct? So, if he reaches out
a handspan, Allah reaches back to him a
cubit. And if he reaches out to Allah a
cubit, Allah reaches back out to him
a bath, which is an entire arm's length.
We understand this to mean that every
time you make an effort to reach out to
Allah, he reaches out to you twice as
much. At least twice as much. And it has
to be that way, otherwise we would never
be able to reach excellence. How could
we? Where do we draw our excellence
from? Where does it come from?
It comes from Allah. He has to give it
to us.
Therefore, if Allah only gives us what
we already have, we would never be able
to get better.
This is why when we reach out to Allah a
handspan, he reaches out a cubit. It
must be that way. Imagine if you could
only get money from me.
Let's say you could only get money from
me.
And you must pay me back
every dollar that you that I give you.
Could you ever have money beyond what I
give you?
It's impossible.
If I give you $10, you have to give me
10 back. There's no way for you to ever
work up out of that.
What about if you can only get money
from me
and then I charge you interest on the
money that you can only get from me?
Wouldn't that be diabolical?
Huh? You can get $10 from me,
but I need you to return it as 12. But
the extra $2 you have to get from me as
well.
And those $2 that you give to me, I need
you to give them back as four. Could you
ever pay me back? Is it possible?
That's the Federal Reserve in a
nutshell. Anyways, side issue. The point
being
that
we only are able to excel as much as
Allah gives us and allows us. So, of
course, he must give us back twice-fold,
and that is why he is Al-Kareem,
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He is the generous
one. He is the source of our excellence,
but not only that, but when he gives us
excellence, he praises us and rewards us
for something that he gave us in the
first place. How much more generous
could anyone be?
And so,
during these days,
when you want to reach out to Allah, if
you make the slightest effort,
if you inch your way to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala, you will be rewarded in droves
and exponentially.
If you hope
to receive blessing from Allah, to
change your ways, for your repentance to
be accepted, for your repentance to be
continuous, if you hope to excel and be
better and learn, these are the days to
start that.
More than Ramadan, you know the masjid
fills up during Ramadan,
but during the first 10 days of Dhul
Hijjah, where is the masjid? Not as
full. Is it as full as it is during
Ramadan? No. Why? Ignorance. That's the
only reason.
Because these days are far superior than
all of the days of Ramadan combined. All
of them combined
do not make up
these first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah.
[Arabic recitation]